bom dia como você já sabe eu vou
compartilhar uma história que na verdade
ele encara mais uma aventura com uma
história uma aventura que eu pude vê-la
da minha avó e pra isso
quero começar apresentando o melhor para
vocês quando ela se a minha avó estava
vivendo a melhor fase da vida dela
aonde ela pôde finalmente aproveitar uma
adolescência passou por diversas
dificuldades quando era nova trabalhando
desde os 13 anos e infelizmente não pode
ter nenhuma infância e uma adolescência
e foi com um grupo de terceira idade que
ela começou a flertar viajar dançar
aproveitar um pouco mas daí eu nasci e
ela aceitou esse neco bem como uma
vovozinha assim que você imagina
pato pegou depois sentou na cadeira de
balanço e daí ela pode curtir toda a
minha criação
me deixando com bagagem disse que a
galera minha avó era o tipo de bloco e
hoje se eu quisesse cachorro quente
pizza agulha não voltou a fazer mas eu
também era metros
se ela quiser jogar canastra dominó
procurava jogar sempre fui muito
apaixonado pela minha volta e acho que
hoje no brasil nós temos dois tipos de
brasileiro
os que não respeitam os idosos e os que
colocam o idoso e um patamar abaixo de
deus
daí ficou como vocês podem ver a minha
geração da minha vó obviamente de ações
bem diferentes
ela deu situações revoluções e guerras
que eu tive que estudar qual é então é
difícil uma aproximação entre essas duas
gerações e quando há essa relação formal
à onde o idoso está lá em cima ea gente
tem que tratar ele com toda a
normalidade possível
torna mais difícil ainda esse jovem se
relacione com o idoso
eu acho que esse é um trabalho da
geração do meio meus pais fizeram isso
com excelência e eu pude descobrir o
primeiro segredo que eu descobri que
minha avó um segredo em ter relações
seja ter pai e mãe entre
o nep e avó
a amizade é agora mais minha vó
ela era minha grande amiga só com 2008
tudo mudou em minha volta e
diagnosticada com alzheimer
você sabe exatamente a causa mas na
época as coisas e tudo bem vai continuar
e só que não dá pra aqueles dois amigos
lá o google e wikipédia é o doutor
google chama hoje porque era pobre e que
se ela vai muito provavelmente vai vir a
morrer
zaine isso causa um impacto tremendo
imagina ele começa a te perguntar nós
porque com ela porque não sofreu tanto
foi pobre trabalha há 13 anos até sua
aposentadoria não pôde viajar porque com
ela agora necessário da vida eo medo
será que ela vai vencer será que ela
realmente vai esquecer meu neto dela e
esse medo e essas perguntas ficam todos
os dias a cabeça na corda com essas
perguntas até o momento em que decidi
não vai parar de fazer as perguntas
erradas é por natureza
então passei a me perguntar o que eu
posso fazer para que a minha avó tem
agora 78 anos a melhor infância do mundo
porque se eu vou ter que encarar da
melhor forma possível
realmente algumas coisas a gente nunca
esquece
então vou contar pra vocês como é que
esse medo de ser esquecido pela minha
avó foi esperado
um dia eu estava com ela na verdade
e ela olhou pra mim e perguntou eu tenho
netos eo e arrasado e dava a ela todos
os dias e ela me pergunta isso eu olhei
pra ela disse sim votem nessas e os seus
problemas
ela sentou do meu lado e passou a mão na
cabeça e disse assim avó sabia que tinha
muitas relacionam lembra então todas as
vezes que ela me esquecia
ela leva pra mim olhar e dizia eu te amo
demais mas o vizinho meu amigo meu primo
então sorria e dizia não interessa só
não sabe que me ama
a senhora tem saber isso que a senhora
me ama e eu te amo e que o ataque tinha
então realmente a gente tenha outros
medos errados
o medo que elas necessitem o neto
que besteira eu tenho medo que ela
esqueça mesmo e agora não tinha mais a
si mesmo como eu ia ter que encarar essa
situação de alguma forma que chega à
estalagem percebe que não há uma cura
chega de bater nessa tecla
não há uma cura não tem reversão vai ter
como consequência uma forma eu resolvi
seguir os conselhos do pet anos e deve
concordar eu acho que iria pode ser sim
o melhor remédio porque os comprimidos
eles cubram o corpo mas só a gargalhada
e amor são capazes de alcançar a alma e
realmente pra alma nesse estágio da
minha vida no início do ano passado que
eu decidi que eu ia ficar tudo aquilo
que eu poderia voltar depois que a
faculdade de filosofia uma mesma empresa
irei para além de neto amigo melhor
amigo agora parte daqueles muito projeto
que faz nesse tal que acorda coisa boa
que leva pra andar de balanço na
presente data brinquedo
eu era o pai
mas eu já tenho que tratar com isso com
essa doença
uma boa senão eu ia acontecer
a minha mãe também teve depressão e eu
vi que minha volta me entra nesse
momento distinto é só virar pai e
utilizar o humor como resposta para
resgatar minha família toda
daí eu quero mostrar pra vocês um
pouquinho do resultado desse bom humor
como funciona a vida o que ela tava
afiadinha
a piada e chorar a bola rola a bola rola
com a moça
falando na unisul button que não pode
nem pensar em alguém é e da briga está
aí bate palma
eu vou te amo esse é o combustível
para que eu pudesse voltar outro dia eu
tinha que ouvir isso todos os dias
o máximo que pudesse estava certo e ela
aceitou o humor também contratou e deu
muito certo inclusive para quem tem
algum caso como esse na família
o alzheimer é um campo muito perde o bom
humor muito caro uma vez a votação caso
mas eu cheguei ali no bar da minha avó
de votos era uma carteira inteira chegar
só de manhã estava demais
ela continua a fazer pois somente assim
não só eu cantando é aquela não é um
carro com uma amiga minha que cigarro da
cidade que nunca vai esquecer já colocou
alguma simpatia é uma coisa é certa o
san luis não porque os novos
parei de novo realmente dominou e todas
as outras situações quando ela acordava
de madrugada e procurar um cachorro que
nós não tínhamos dentro de um lugar onde
não caberia lado do cachorro com o dia a
dia da melhor forma possível
bom deu certo pra mim podia dar certo
por lá no início de abril saiba toda a
informação que havia sobre alzheimer é
você não vai conseguir
você vai acontecer com totó talvez morto
antes era estónia
isso afasta o familiar cuidador do
portador geral abandono
como deu certo pra mim eu queria
compartilhar com os outros o que mostrar
e compartilhar com vocês a minha dor não
impliquem sofrermos todos juntos mas eu
posso lembrar que dessa dor só isso como
a seguinte para uma página
facebook.com barba nível e ele começou a
compartilhar o seu dia-a-dia nossos
casos esses diálogos hilários e sem
sentido algum
vídeos fotos e foi crescendo hoje a
página tem quase 100 mil pessoas pessoas
compartilham comigo
os benefícios desta página nas suas
vidas compartilham comigo as suas vidas
e coisas que poderiam ter fusionado
comigo também
e essa rede de contatos foi maravilhoso
já deve ter visto pela corrente do bem
aonde um livre faz uma coisa boa
realmente boa para três pessoas e essas
pessoas são empregadas fazer uma coisa
boa para mais três pessoas e assim vai
se formando uma corrente
hoje eu tenho 100 meo é a luz da minha
corrente quase 100 mil é uma comédia uma
corrente que me ajudou durante o período
em que cuidava da minha avó me ajudou
durante o luto e me ajuda hoje
percebendo que através da nossa história
possa ajudar outras famílias a lição de
vida que aprendi com a minha vó o outro
segredo ea última edição quando a avó
suspirou na última vez eu chorei mas eu
também sou eu descobrir que levava
ensinou que a superação da morte ela não
tá a morte de mais uma vez ser uma hora
pela errada e tenta superar a ausência
das pessoas que nós amamos
depois de duas partidas eu já tinha
superado a ausência da minha vó vida
toda vez que ia mandar de balanço na
praça toda vez que a gente já na padaria
comprar o dossiê que ela mais gostava ou
toda vez que a gente falava no maldito
pinõn a gente sempre estava em um eterno
processo de superação e ela só me deixou
quando ela sentiu eu estava realmente
pronto
não só para ver desenho ela sem a filha
mas para compartilhar com outras pessoas
para que ela pudesse mudar a vida de
outras pessoas diz hoje um livro que
essas pessoas pediram que nós prevemos
que eu comecei a escrever uma tela
infelizmente ela vai aparecer no meio
desse processo em dezembro do ano
passado ele foi lançado em homenagem
também para ajudar outras famílias nessa
caminhada que a onlive é um desafio mas
também pode ser uma aventura a gente não
precisa pensar sempre no negativo a
doença já é negativa
se não vão sair do número desistam para
procurar uma cura para de procurar uma
saída
a saída é encarar a situação e encarar a
qualidade de vida que tem que aumentar
esse livro hoje muito positiva de
pessoas que dizem olha a minha mãe tinha
alzheimer e esse livro me ajudou a criar
uma amizade com a mãe mesmo com a vaga
porque enquanto há vida há sensibilidade
a prazer há medo ela está viva ela sente
ela é usada na moda só tem para dar a
ela a usar não deixa nem sentado que ela
vai crescer mesmo não não é assim
ela vai lembrar do momento no momento as
empresas portuguesas pouco interessam
quando eu vejo o sorriso
o zagueiro hoje eu quero que você
levanta a mão
todos que têm um pai uma mãe ou avós com
aqui como levantado agora levanta a mão
as pessoas que conhecem alguém próximo
que tem essa metade de casa agora
envolve o alzheimer hoje só nos estados
unidos
em 68 segundos uma pessoa recebe nosso
no mundo já são mais de 35 milhões de
portadores de alzheimer
esse número pode multiplicar por três
porque a família está doente e 1
enquanto não descobre uma forma de
conviver com isso
35 milhões mas até 2050 esse número vai
triplicar
mas finalmente ultrapassando cansa de
nome
será que o brasil está pronto para
encarar usuário
será que nós brasileiros não só política
mas nós mesmos
discutimos suficiente a respeito do
investimento e do envelhecimento com
obstáculo à minha vó na saúde pública
com todos os desafios e obstáculos à
saúde pública pode dizer com propriedade
nós não estamos prontos até porque não
há política pro doente ideia para a
família
se o governo não vai dar condições de
cuidar do meu pai mãe avó como é que vai
acabar eu tenho depressão é tão ruim e
ela esses dias no lançamento do livro em
um estado e houve uma senhora dizendo
ainda que chama de boi público essa
vergonha de envelhecer impede brasileiro
de envelhecimento mas em alguns anos o
zagueiro vai triplicar porque a gente
vive se iludindo com aquele tipo de
notícia que nos diz o brasileiro está
vivendo mais mas a que preço
obrigado